[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires sur
tv5monde en direct avec nos partenaires
de la presse quotidienne régionale vous
pouvez voir ou revoir cette émission en
direct sur le site de ouest france.fr de
nicematin.com de france antilles point
fr de la montagne.fr avec une reprise
sur 20minutes.fr ce matin m'ont invité
c'est gérard longuet bonjour mais
dangereux avec nous gérard longuet vous
êtes ancien ministre de la défense bien
sûr sénateur de la meuse vous êtes
ancien liste de françois mitterrand à
nicolas sarkozy ses tunnels de
régularité les deux et vous avez été
aussi longtemps 12 ans président de la
conseil régional de lorraine nous y
tenons ici dans cette émission face aux
territoires merci d'être avec nous
gérard longuet évidemment l'actualité et
à marioupol ce matin bombardement d'un
théâtre abritant des centaines de civils
on pense qu'il a été la cible d'une
frappe aérienne russe bien sûr
volontaire nombre de victimes inconnu à
dubaï d'un a raison quand il dit que
vadimir poutine c'est un criminel de
guerre il avait déjà dit la vérité était
un criminel dans une conversation qu'un
jour ou qui avaient été enregistrés qui
avait un petit peu étonné 13 est très
honnêtement aujourd'hui oui il a raison
le l'attitude de la russie de poutine et
l'attitude de poutine personnellement
puisque c'est lui qui porte cette
offensive est parfaitement inacceptable
et il savait également que toute
offensive militaire sur des villes
peuplées par des millions de civils les
grandes villes ukrainiennes se
traduirait nécessairement par des
destructions
d'objectifs afin de pas de situations
civile d'hôpitaux d'universités de
bâtiments ça veut dire qu'il ne craint
pas au fond le jugement de
l'international c'est en ce sens qu'il
est et qui prend le risque d'être
criminel
il se donne tous les droits c'est un
ciné inacceptable 800 millions de
dollars des deux militaires
supplémentaires à l'ukraine a annoncé
joe by dernière
est ce que cela peut faire la différence
notamment vous êtes ancien ministre de
la défense dans les airs qui est la
problématique du président zine ce qui
aujourd'hui est là non ça ne sera pas la
différence
800 millions c'est une somme importante
cela permet en particulier aux
ukrainiens de se fournir en drones et
les drones de combat de nouvelle
génération peuvent assurer une forme de
protection est compliqué
vie des appareils russes au dessus des
villes assiégées mais l'armement c'est
hélas une évidence ça coûte très cher et
surtout il faut le mettre en oeuvre avec
des gens formés avec une logistique qui
assure l'approvisionnement
parce que si vous avez le système mais
qu'il vous manque tel ou tel équipement
il devient inutile et donc les 800
millions de dollars c'est un geste
significatif et dans ce climat de crise
c'est d'ailleurs une performance que
l'armée ukrainienne qui n'est pas
considérable
puisse tenir encore comme elle tient
gérard longuet l'ancien ministre de la
défense est notre invité ce matin en
face aux territoires dans un instant
laurent marchand rédacteur en chef
délégué chargé des affaires
internationales de ouest france sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
bonjour laurent marchand dans un instant
nous allons interviewé gérard longuet
ensemble je mets tout de suite françois
xavier le francky et rédacteur en chef
de ouest france qui est à rennes en
duplex à une question à vous poser
gérard longuet sur la défense européenne
en l'écoutent bonjour monsieur longuet
vous avez été ministre de la défense et
la défense est une question que certains
français voyait peut-être d'un peu loin
ces derniers temps et l'actualité nous
rattrape elle nous met sous les yeux une
évidence c'est une affaire sérieuse
la défense de la france la défense de
l'europe la défense européenne est une
nécessité il en va de notre liberté il
en va de notre indépendance quelle forme
doit prendre cet effort européen de
défense l'allemagne vient d'annoncer un
geste spectaculaire près de 100
milliards d'euros d'investissements et
des dépenses qui pourront aller jusqu'à
2% de son produit intérieur brut et
peut-être plus donc quelle forme doit
prendre cet effort de défense européen
nécessaire aujourd'hui je crois que la
première règle en matière de défense est
d'avoir une solidarité politique très
forte car
l'emploi des armes n'a de sens que si
l'on sait ce que l'on veut obtenir et de
ce point de vue
la première la première condition est de
savoir
voulons-nous décider ensemble à quelles
règles de majorité décidons nous
ensemble et quels sont les adversaires
que nous avons identifiées ensemble et à
ces trois questions il n'y a pas de
réponse très claire jusqu'à présent la
dernière question étant la plus dure non
oui mais le
la résoudre absolue absolument mais ce
qui est nouveau et c'est en effet
poutine qui a rendu cela possible c'est
qu'on ose poser la question ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant avant oui non
la défense nous nos partenaires en
europe les et la défense et l'otan
bon
qu'il y ait eu des initiatives déjà deux
d'avancé de l'union européenne en
matière de défense est une évidence
depuis une dizaine d'années je l' ai
d'ailleurs mesuré moi même lorsque j'ai
jeté mise à défense des avancées mais il
n'y avait pas de système aujourd'hui à
la perspective d'un système faut-il
aller plus loin dans l'aide militaire
aux ukrainiens
déjà il faut faire ce que l'on a à faire
le crâne est un état indépendant
qui est envahi par son voisin et qui a
le droit de s'approvisionner en
équipements militaires en armements
défensifs offensif elle a le droit de le
faire ce n'est pas un ce sont les règles
internationales qui le permettent
l'union européenne dit oui pour des
armes défensives ce qui entre nous
n'avons 15 ans joe klein ça ne s'est pas
très clair parce que est ce qu'un
missile milan est ce qu'un jaglin ce
casting heures sont défensif oui sont
des vans évidement des avions les
polonais étaient sur le cas lors de les
avions c'est un autre c'est un autre
problème c'est que les armes au sol
employé par le fantassin ce sont des
armes qui peuvent être employées je
dirais dans un ordre non pas dispersée
mais avec une certaine liberté d'emplois
quand vous êtes dans un système aérien
il faut c'est un système complet il vous
faut à la fois des satellites il vous
faut des avions de surveillance qui
surveille le terrain de au sens large le
terrain d'opération des awacs en général
et vous avez des appareils qui sont
reliés à la fois avec des hommes au sol
pour guider les tirs et avec un système
global or nous ne pouvons pas engager ce
système
le bal parce que cela voudrait dire que
l'otan et belligérants dans la danse est
comment évaluez-vous le risque qu'on le
devienne malgré tout malgré nous alors
tant qu on est sur des opérations
ponctuelles au sol le risque est
permanent par exemple une livraison
d'armes
normalement elle se fait à la frontière
en quelque sorte mais on imagine assez
bien qu un moment ou un autre les russes
vont s'efforcer ce qu'ils ne font pas
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
le faire de contrôler les frontières
ouest de l'ukraine c'est à dire la
pologne la hongrie la tchéquie pour
autant que je me souviennes slovaquie ce
vague et pardon et puis évidemment la
roumanie et à cet instant ses frontières
peuvent devenir des sujets d escalade un
convoi c'est eux qui décident en voyant
s'il considère que salée ou pas les deux
parce que le nous nous livrons des armes
mais il ya un moment il faut qu'elle
soit emportée emporté par qui et avec
quels moyens et ça c'est à ce moment là
que ça devient compliqué et que
l'escaladé possible mais c'est une
escale j'ai presque envie dias une
escalade ponctuelle on l'a vu par
exemple entre la russie et la turquie
dans la fir syrienne à certains moments
il ya eu des affrontements md je crois
un avion russe qui étaient abattus par
un avion turc houle lots contraire et la
réciproque ce sont des escalades qu'on
arrive encore à maîtriser ce qui serait
extraordinairement dangereux c'est une
escalade
évidemment et la no fly zone valeur la
zone de contrôle aérien pour dire des
choses en français
c'est une source permanente d escalade
je crois que l'otan en tous les cas les
pays voisins ne le ne pourront aider les
ukrainiens et les ukrainiens le ca
l'accord de 97 entre la russie et l'otan
prévoyait qui n'est pas d'installation
de base permanente de l'otan dans les
pays nouveaux membres
le moment est il venu de mettre des
c'est ce que demande la pologne les pays
baltes peut mettre des bases permanentes
de l'otan
quand on le faire maintenant
non il faut le gars il faut garder cette
installation tu ne sortiras pas
d'intérêt tactique à très court terme le
tank leva soit installé c'est une
affaire assez
l'ong donc je crois qu'il faut garder
cette option comme un élément dans la
négociation qui inévitablement un moment
ou un autre s'ouvrira entre la russie
l'ukraine et est en fête et pays
européens mais on voit bien qu'il est
presque impossible de rester non alignés
en ce moment même des pays non alignés
comme la finlande et la suède sentent
qu'ils doivent avoir une protection
latérale et la suède et la finlande sont
non-alignés je rappelle qu'ils ont des
frontières communes avec la russie et
que et les raisons historiques surtout
pour la finlande d'ailleurs de se méfier
de leurs voisins et donc ce sont des
pays qui était alors la finlande
officiellement non-alignés par un accord
international et de l'héritage en fait
de la guerre 1940 entre la finlande et
la russie que la finlande avait là n'est
pas gagné mais n'avait pas perdu en tous
les cas et les russes les soviétiques à
l'époque on était obligé de de calais et
de reconnaître un cône elle neutralise
neutralité de la finlande ce qui était
pour la finlande à un immense succès la
suède c'est différent c'est un choix
elle a fait le choix d'être ne tel n'a
été vis-à-vis de l'allemagne pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale elle a été
vis-à-vis de la russie
bon je n'en dirai pas plus parce que
c'est une affaire un peu compliqué
notamment sur les livraisons de minerai
de fer suédois mais je ferme la
parenthèse ce sont des cas historique la
neutralisation la neutralité de
l'ukraine se fait partie comme les bases
de l'otan d'un climat de négociation
général ce que l'on observe
c'est qu'on n'a pas su tirer les
dividendes de la paix oui on a baissé la
garde sur le plan de la dépense
militaire mais on n'a pas construit le
système politique en europe et on n'a
pas anticipé les difficultés qui est est
inévitable
et de ce point de vue je pense que leurs
hôtes en général la france tout autant
qui est signataire des accords de minsk
2 avec l'allemagne la russie
accord de minuscules sur le cren
nous n'avons peut-être pas suivi
l'application et la mise en oeuvre de
cet accord avec la précision les
exigences de calendrier pour les uns et
pour les autres gérard longuet c'est un
c'est un regret je formule ancien
ministre de la défense est notre invité
ce matin d'en face aux territoires
chaunu qui est dessinateur et
collaborateur régulier de ouest-france à
une question à vous poser sous forme de
dessin c'est la tradition de cette
émission on écoute
inexorablement entre l'ouest et l'est un
fossé se creuse au moment où les
français retire le masque bien les
ukrainiens eux ne sont pas prêts de
l'enlever alors qu emmanuel macron
propose aux corses l'autonomie vladimir
poutine poursuit l'annexion de l'ukraine
alors la question que je pose je la pose
plus au sénateur de la meuse cas
l'ancien ministre de la défense de
nicolas sarkozy pourquoi ne retient t'on
jamais les leçons de l'histoire
c'est une très bonne remarque parce que
nos hommes politiques ne sont pas assez
cultivé ne connaissent pas assez
l'histoire vous vous rappelez que je
suis sénateur de la meuse ceux
d'aujourd'hui ou faire allusion à
sodiaal 20 30 ans en général et est
beaucoup pour duisans beaucoup
aujourd'hui parce que nous avons une
société de l'immédiat une société de
l'instantané où il faut pardonnez moi
dans les 20 secondes répondre à des
problèmes majeurs qui n'ont pas été
réglés souvent depuis d'aidé d and d
vingtaine d'années et donc on jongle
avec le 11 janvier avec l'actualité on
ne va pas assez en profondeur en meuse
j'ai fait tellement
de pèlerinage sur des monuments aux
morts de la guerre de 70 de la guerre de
14 de la guerre de 40 et de toutes les
étapes de chacune de ces trois guerres
sont parler des guerres napoléoniennes
que je nous avons assez naturellement
lorraine
le genre de l'histoire et de la
profondeur malheureusement ce n'est pas
partagé par une messe que c'est une
génération qui est un petit peu
superficielle est ce que c'est la
superficialité de cette génération la
force de pénétration de la propagande
russe qui a été déterminante dans ces
dernières années c'est la superficialité
si vous voulez l'histoire reste tragique
et la tentation de la force et
permanente y compris dans des ciels
bleus est serein gérard longuet notre
invité la une de ouest france rapidement
ce matin on la voit énergie un plan
daide face à la flambée des prix merci
laurent marchand merci dans un instant
denis carot de nice matin sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot dans un instant nous
intervieweront gérard longuet sur les
problèmes français aussi et politique
cyril gautier qui est directeur
éditorial de france antilles notre
partenaire à une question à vous poser
avoue l'ancien ministre de la défense
gérard longuet en écoute depuis
fort-de-france bonjour gérard longuet
vous l'évoquez dans les années à venir
l'armée va devoir faire face à de
nouveaux défis géopolitiques dans ce
cadre là selon vous quelle est la place
que doivent occuper les territoires
d'outre-mer en sachant qu'ils sont
chacun dans leur zone géographique
de potentiel base avancée ou base
arrière pour l'outre-mer français
je crois que la première mission c'est
le contrôle de l'espace maritime et de
ceux des familles aux territoriales
voilà les eaux territoriales les zones
d'influencé un mot exact qui m'échappe à
cet instant mais nous avons le deuxième
territoire maritime mondial on le dit on
s'en vante ya eu des conflits iard assez
régulièrement des conventions sur le
sujet de notre de bilan fin de note
présence maritime elle est insuffisante
et aussi bien aux antilles dans le
pacifique ou dans l'océan indien nous
devons avoir une présence maritime avec
naturellement servi par des marins qui
pourraient être plus souvent formés par
les territoires et départements
d'outre-mer denis carot bonjour gérard
longuet jours la france est aujourd'hui
dans une situation paradoxale le
président macron est très haut dans les
sondages beaucoup auprès 10 à sa
réélection mais on sent beaucoup
d'inquiétude beaucoup de colère dans le
pays cette semaine on a vu des
manifestations et des blocages de dépôts
pétroliers à brest lorient et la
rochelle cette colère est ce qu'elle
pourrait s'amplifier à trois mois à
trois semaines du premier tour
il ya une frustration française à
l'égard du régime présidentiel je ne
mets pas en cause la personnalité des
manuels macron qui est la sienne qui est
original la jeunesse sans doute
l'enthousiasmé puis un certain sens de
la transgression et
peut-être même de la provocation dans
les formules non la difficulté c'est
qu'on demande trop au président de la
république en france
et les présidents de la république
accentue cela lorsque celui là plus que
les autres au moins peut-être plus parce
qu'il est plus active sans doute vous
aviez des présidents j'ai connu en effet
françois mitterrand qui avait l'art
d'esquiver les difficultés et de
renvoyer au premier ministre au ministre
aux interlocuteurs les soucis de kiel
qu'aujourd'hui le président se pensent
pense devoir gérer personnellement et
donc il y à il y à cet écart entre
l'allée responsabilité qu'il prend et
puis la possibilité que le chef de
l'état a de régler tous les problèmes il
n'est pas vrai qu'il puisse régler tous
les problèmes tout le temps en
permanence et en direct c'est pas vrai
plutôt différente les français acceptent
l'idée c'est qu'une démocratie c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et ça fonctionne
avec tout le monde ce n'est pas une
pyramide sur la pointe or aujourd'hui on
a une pyramide sur la pointe et ça c'est
pas un truc qui marche alors le
gouvernement entend continuer à régler
les problèmes jean castex a présenté un
plan hier 10 de résilience économique
est ce qu'on peut continuer à aider les
secteurs qui sont en difficulté comme on
l'a fait pendant la crise sanitaire et
quelques parfois qu'ils ont comparu hier
il faut rendre hommage à l'union
européenne
à la mise en place de l'euro qui fait
que nous pouvons le gouvernement
président de la république peut annoncer
à la sa ble ment des dépenses qui avant
la monnaie unique européenne avant
l'euro aurait entraîné immédiatement une
tension sur le franc une montée des taux
d'intérêt et une dégradation de la
valeur de notre monnaie merci l'europe
est gelée vécu en europe c'est ça je
remercie l'europe je les ai vécus avec
jacques chirac premier ministre
mitterrand
président de la république dès que le
président le premier ministre annonçait
des dépenses le franc se dégrader par
rapport aux marques et à ce moment là
tout le monde s'arrêtait donc là on peut
continuer en gage il ya je vous dis
attend que la banque centrale européenne
assure les femmes noires feront on le
fera sauf que on endette le pays dans
des conditions qui sont lourdes très
lourdes et qui son supérieur à la
plupart de nos voisins alors il ya des
réponses qui sont apportées pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français le
gouvernement a gelé le prix le prix du
gaz limiter la hausse du prix de
l'électricité
il a mis en oeuvre un shack inflation il
va mettre en oeuvre une aide de 15
centimes à partir du 1er avril pour le
prix de l'essence est ce que il doit
continuer dans cette voie là il le fait
avec au prix d'un endettement que nous
aurons à rembourser
heureusement cet endettement aujourd'hui
se faire un taux d'intérêt encore faible
le jour où les taux d'intérêt remontent
les successeurs de monsieur castex même
le président macron ayant un succès sur
un jour auront une dette à rembourser
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons à
crédit tout ce qu'annonce le président
de la république ce sont des chèques sur
l'avenir qui constituent des dettes il
faut bien il faut bien savoir cet argent
n'est pas magique le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est très sympathique sur l'instant
mais on charge la barque de dette qu'il
faudra n'ont pas remboursé parce qu'on
n'y arrivera pas mais à schumer c'est à
dire payer l'été les intérêts l'accord
sous tension de nouri gérald darmanin
est en corse depuis hier il a ouvert la
voie au principe de l'autonomie de la
corse qui étaient refusés jusqu'à
présent c'est la voix de la raison
que veut dire autonomie de la corse
quand on sait que cette ce département
français vit en symbiose totale avec la
république et c'est normal puisque c'est
une parcelle importante est imminente de
notre territoire donc parler d'autonomie
on ne sait absolument pas ce que cela
c'est intimidant de la part du
gouvernement électoraliste se
rajouterait j -c d'opportunités si ça
peut faire tomber la fièvre très bien
mais je ferais remarquer que le
président mc ren est à la tête de l'état
depuis cinq ans qu'il est allé en corse
et il avait lu sans doute mesuré les
problèmes je n'ai pas le souvenir que
ces deux mises intérieur précédent
collomb et darmana est proposé quoi que
ce soit de concret aux corses pour
autant les cordes aucun petit peu de
retard à l'allumage dans leur découverte
de la question corps les corps se sont
pour beaucoup est pour même pour la
plupart favorables à cette autonomie
mais tout le monde est favorable à
l'autonomie jusqu'au jour où on en fixe
les conditions ce que le problème de la
corse et que c'est une île entourée
d'eau et tout est beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est d'ailleurs une île
montagneuse où la vie est très
compartimenté et où l'implantation n'a
essayé de le faire l'implantation
d'activités nouvelles et presque
impossible parce que l'activité
industrielle n'est pas facile l'activité
agricole est limité et le tourisme les
corps sont favorables donc on les
comprend à condition de ne pas être
dépossédés or le tourisme entraîne d'une
façon ou d'une autre une certaine
dépossession par les habitants de leur
territoire donc le problème corse ni ne
se réglera pas en 48 heures sur un coin
de table avec une formule type autonomie
denis carot la une de nice matin au
chevet des d'ukrainiens les
alpes-maritimes c'est la première terre
d'accueil de réfugiés en france en ce
moment et la solidarité se met en place
avec notamment un ancien hôpital qui est
transformé en centre d'hébergement géant
à nice en plein coeur de la ville petit
formidable et aussi les élans de
solidarité dénis soir heureux liés par
nice matin je le sais donc à regarder
sur nice et bruges et généreux
merci denis carot directeur
deux des rédactions du groupe nice matin
qui comprend aussi var-matin bien sûr
gérard longuet je sais que vous avez un
attachement particulier pour le
département du var c'est le département
de françois léotard en effet voilà dans
un instant amène le goff de 20 minutes
[Musique]
bonjour armelle le goff vous êtes la
diact ledger élections de 20 minutes je
le disais dans un instant nous avons
parlé dans dans un instant et vous du
prix de l'indépendance mais tout de
suite notre partenaire du groupe centre
france la montagne gérard longuet
aujourd'hui c'est pierre françois chez
taille qui appartient au journal le pays
c'est un journaleux hebdomadaire du
groupe la montagne centre france il a
une question à vous poser depuis roanne
on l'écouté
monsieur longuet bonjour depuis 2009
comme vous le savez la france fait
partie du commandement intégré de l'otan
vous avez été ministre de la défense peu
après d'ailleurs cette décision décision
qui est remise en cause par un certain
nombre de candidats à la présidentielle
certains think cela mais la france
mettrait la france en danger et
risquerait de l'engager dans un conflit
mondial qu'il n'a concerne leur école
alors faire partie de l'automne et ne
sont vraiment pas intégrées elles
seraient réellement une protection pour
nos compatriotes ou est-ce que cela peut
représenter aussi un certain danger
c'est en effet une obligation c'est une
contrainte mais c'est un choix que le
président sarkozy a fait avec beaucoup
de raisons parce que en étant absent du
commandement intégré nous avions à peu
près tous les inconvénients sans aucun
avantage c'est à dire que nous aurions
été
embarqués dans toutes situations
difficiles par solidarité et nous
n'aurions pas pu participer en amont à
la désision je crois que nicolas sarkozy
a eu raison de le faire et son succès
ses successeurs soit hollande ou
emmanuel macron n'ont pas remis en cause
ce choix armelle le goff le prix de
l'indépendance de la france oui vous
avez déclaré qu'un état trop
déficitaires règne toujours sur le
régalien seuls les états qui conserve
des marges budgétaires peuvent préparer
une guerre avez vous ajouté
la france dans le pire des cas ne serait
donc pas prêtes de votre point de vue
il ya un vrai problème d'indépendance
française je le dis très clairement fin
vers une évidence quand vous avez une
balance commerciale
structurellement déficitaire d'année en
année alors que des voix des pays comme
l'italie ou l'allemagne longtemps ça
veut dire que vous n'êtes pas capables
de vendre et vous me contenter d'acheter
or ces déficits montre que vous dépendez
de l'extérieur parce que vous n'êtes pas
capables de présenter les produits les
équipements qui les services qui font
que les gens aient envie des chevaux
deuxième déficit dangereux c'est le
déficit de la dépense publique parce que
pour être indépendant il faut être le
plus moderne possible et fois
technologique pas dans tous les domaines
pour un pays comme le nôtre 65 millions
c'est à la fois beaucoup et à la taille
de géant comme la russie ou la chine ou
les etats-unis la russie c'est marginal
maintenant
l'on peut pas tout faire mais si on a un
déficit de la dépense publique parce que
on tire des chèques sur l'avenir on ne
peut on va sacrifier les investissements
regardez aujourd'hui l'énergie nous
avions bien mûri whist sur les plans des
parlementaires ont remis un rapport mi
février sur nos capacités dans le
contexte d'une guerre de haute intensité
et ils disent qu'on ne pourrait pas
faire face à la russie par on a un
problème par exemple c'est vrai trois
jours et nous n'avons pas de stock on à
renier sur la mise en condition
opérationnelle le maintien en condition
opérationnelle les équipements et on n'a
pas les réserves de munitions à
l'argument qui a rogné d'une façon
constante je dirais depuis 30 ans les
façon constante depuis 30 ans parce que
les militaires ont obtenu et c'est bien
ce gouvernement a poursuivi ce que
d'autres avaient fait d'eux les grands
programmes d'équipement mais à côté des
programmes d'équipement ce que
j'appelais la mise en condition
opérationnelle l'entraînement et les
stocks de combat et d'ailleurs on sait
exactement comme les masques en fait on
prépare une guerre à laquelle on ne
croit pas donc on a les équipements
francky qui permettent de
de dire ça y est on à l'aviation
l'aéronautique pour formidable et puis
derrière ben s'il faut mettre en oeuvre
plusieurs jours de suite on s'aperçoit
qu'au plan de l'entraînement des
théâtres d'opération comme le sahel par
exemple ce sont des zones où l'armée
française oui mais justement le le
fonctionnement ce qu'on appelle des opex
normalement les opex ont financé au delà
des budgets de la défense par l'ensemble
du budget c'est plus le cas depuis cinq
ans c'était le cas encore du temps de
monsieur sarkozy depuis françois
hollande et depuis mes manuels macron ce
n'est plus le cas c'est à dire que le
budget de feu d'équipement de l'armée et
de fonctionnement de l'armée c'est
d'ailleurs justement cet entretien que
j'évoquais finance les opex or une
opération à l'extérieur si on la décide
il faut savoir que ça va coûter toujours
sur lui donna il faut trouver de
l'argent en plus toujours à la place
toujours sur le plan d'un dépendent de
l'indépendance sur le plan de l'énergie
vous vous positionnez très clairement en
faveur de l'énergie nucléaire ce que
vous pouvez détailler votre position là
tu pourquoi c'est important d'après vous
parce que nous avons réussi à voir 70 80
% avec l'hydraulique de notre énergique
et décarbonées ce qui est bien une régie
électrique qui est décarbonée nous avons
demain dans l'avenir l'automobile qui va
passer à l'électricité progressivement
plus ou moins rapidement selon les
points de vue nous allons avoir le rôle
de l'hydrogène qui est un vecteur pour
stocker pour transférer 30 pour déplacer
de l'énergie mais le l'hydrogène est une
énorme consommateur d'électricité et
vous avez un troisième sujet de
consommation électrique qui est
l'intelligence artificielle au sens
large tous les systèmes numériques ces
trois facteurs me font penser que la
consommation électrique va augmenter
sans doute de 50% dans les vingt ans or
c'est exactement le contraire de ce que
le de ce que nous annonçait le ministre
de la transition énergétique qui nous
est gentiment que ça marche pas les
énergies alternatives c'est pas grand
chose mais c'est pas suffisant et puis
surtout c'est parfaitement aléatoire
c'est à dire que il fait beau il ya les
éoliennes ne tourne pas il fait froid
les éoliennes ne tourne sur le plan
agricole on s'aperçoit qu'on est
dépendant aussi au niveau du blé là
aussi si vous la politique la politique
imprudente qui consiste à dire oui on va
faire que du bio que de la qualité on va
aller de duchamp à la fourchette le plus
gros possible plus à ces visages en
cours samedi l'apprécié pas mal non mais
si vous voulez c'est très sympa moi je
vais chercher mes mirabel dans les
coteaux des côtes de meuse mars et c'est
avec plaisir et puis j'ai mon petit
fournisseur qui me donne mon vin vous
craignez le plan géopolitique mais le
les gros bataillons si vous voulez la
paix en afrique du nord depuis le maroc
jusqu'à l'egypte et bien c'est les
exportations françaises ukrainiennes ou
russes de blé et autres actions dernière
question d'actualité on approche du 19
mars 62 dette anniversaire du
cessez-le-feu en algérie emmanuel macron
sur le plan des relations franco
algériennes a pu avoir des mots forts
comme reconnaître la colonisation commet
un crime contre l'humanité mais aussi
avoir des mots très durs contre le
pouvoir algérien qu'est ce que vous
pensez de sa politique sur ce plan il
aurait mieux fait de réfléchir avant et
tourner sa langue sept fois dans sa
bouche comme souvent on le conseillait
autrefois aux enfants ils manquent de
culture à l'aise sur le canal entre
l'humanité c'était un s'était
parfaitement scandaleux il faut comme on
dit aujourd'hui contextualiser la
colonisation c'est pas des pages
forcément sympathique il ya eu des
moments de tension mais il faut le
relier à une époque et un une forme de
progrès et sa emmanuel macron réinvente
moi-même à ce sujet mais la vie va pas
remis alors il a réussi à se fâcher avec
les pieds noirs et avec les algériens
parce que la rente mémorielle sur
laquelle vit le fln c'est une évidence
donc c'est un homme assez surprenant il
est
le mot à la mode c'est disruptif c'est à
dire qu'ils aiment bien jouer les
éléphants dans les magasin de porcelaine
sauf que la porcelaine quand on vous la
case c'est que c'est la vôtre ça vous
embête là il a joué le en même temps un
comme comme souvent non la célèbre après
l'autre il a commencé par tant de la
main les algériens et il n'a pas été
pris en considération et donc il a il a
réussi là d'une vérité qui était bon de
rappeler en effet la une de 20minutes
les airs mais c'est un focus sur le film
de jean jacques annaud qui plonge le
spectateur dans l' incendie de la
cathédrale parisienne comme
un grand cinéaste armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
merci à vous dans un instant sylvia
garcia de tv5 monde sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour sylvia garcia journaliste à la
rédaction de tv5monde la partie
internationale de cette émission gérard
longuet président du groupe france
russie quel rôle vous pouvez jouer en ce
moment avec l'invasion à de l'ukraine
par la russie ce que à votre niveau le
canal est ouvert le canal de discussion
je dis très clairement la seule chose
que nous faisons d'une passion dutil
actuellement c'est de chercher des
interlocuteurs et des bons connaisseurs
de la russie pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui se passe les raisons les
motivations est ce qu'il y à un
isolement de poutine ce qu'il y à une
adhésion et cette information nous la
donnons comme le fait ma collègue à
l'assemblée nationale le nom aux
sénateurs et aux députés et aux
sénateurs mais je me refuse totalement
dans ce contexte à à établir des liens
je connais le président de la douma et
le président du conseil de la fédération
qui est l'équivalent du sénat en russie
aucune envie de l'appeler parce que il
va être obligé de tenir un langage
je dirais langue de bois mais le contact
pourrait être interprété comme une
faiblesse est jeune on emmanuel macron
lui est en contact avec le présent c'est
son job
vous l'avait accompagné à saint louis
dans ce bourg vous disiez à l'époque il
a une analyse lucide de la situation pas
dupes de ces relations amicales avec
poutine joe site est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui le bon interlocuteur pour
essayer de faire changer des présidents
français et je pense que la france a
suffisamment d'autorité
pour être un acteur
d'une négociation qui devra venir
forcément il n'y aura pas de de retrait
de ce russe il n'y aura pas de darwin de
cessez le feu c'est sans diplomatie et
le président de la république française
est dans son rôle et nous devons le
soutenir dans ce rôle mais cherche la
paix en vendant des armes et la russie
c'est une position un peu délicate alors
là la vente d armes à la russie c'est en
effet un instant barral louper c'est un
loupé du gouvernement français avec la
vente des armes est soumise à la
commission interministérielle
d'exportation de matériel de guerre la c
ie mg et 7 cmg thorne aurait dû se poser
la question on a su par exemple c'était
françois hollande revenir sur la vente
des bateaux dits bcb bateau de
projection et de commandement on les a
fait rapatrier ils ont été d'ailleurs
revendu à l'egypte après je pense que
pour les entreprises qui ont été cités
il eût été préférable
et depuis la
lie respect des accords de minsk se
d'arrêter s'est passé entre nous dit-on
légal et repose sur des contrats
antérieurs sanctions d'euros lt légal
mais c'est pas très moral est-ce que
avec l'opinion publique aujourd'hui qui
est très favorable aux ukrainiens ces
armes qui ont été vendus apparemment
servirait à tuer des civils craignent
aujourd'hui servent à combattre et à
abattre
j'étais là leur mire et autres ministres
comme anciens me lisent la défense j'ai
été vraiment le premier étonné que la c
ie mg qui est quand même sous l'autorité
du gouvernement est accepté ses
exportations
de l'ue salue les suspens ce sont des
exportations qui ne concerne pas que la
russie la france et pointé du droit
régulièrement a fait l'objet de
critiques pour son soutien à des régimes
comme l'arabie saoudite vous évoquez
d'égypte l'instant qui l'un des
principaux clients de la france en tant
que ministre de la défense de la défense
ancien ministre de la défense qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ces critiques
malheureusement l'indépendance français
nous en parlions il ya quelques instants
avec un landreau prédécesseurs je
suppose d'avoir une industrie de défense
et il n'y a pas d'industrie de défense
avec la seule commande du ministère
français de la défense nationale et donc
nous sommes tenus de vendre et c'est il
est vrai que nous vendons à des pays qui
ont des besoins alors pas ce qu'ils font
l'objet d'interdictions par les accords
internationaux nations unies ou des
accords avec les états unis par exemple
y faire un peu comme dans le golfe
persique il y as nous avons vendu des
armes mais pas certaines armes parce
qu'elles sont interdites on respecte les
accords internationaux qui font que
certains pays sont hors sujet c'est
l'arabie saoudite n'est pas dans ce cas
on va juste changer de sujet parce qu'il
nous reste une petite minute vues
d'afrique maintenant la russie a fait un
retour remarqué sur le continent ces
dernières années est ce que aujourd'hui
il va devoir revoir est-ce que ça va
être l'occasion pour la france je vous
dire sur l'adour il serait intéressant
parce qu'il montre qu'il est scandaleux
je veux dire que les équipes wagner car
en fait c'est pas l'air serré des
milices fatna emily's wagner vivent au
détriment des pays africains en les
pillant et dire que l'on reproche à la
france d'avoir été il y a maintenant 70
ans un pays colonisateur et on accepte
que des gouvernements je pense
centrafrique
concède des droits dessus sol
c'est-à-dire vendre la tri moine rescapé
de financer l'achat de milices gré alors
que jeudi
je veux dire avec l'afrique nous avons
des relations anciennes et durable et de
ses en plus contestée notamment par le
non non non non mais elles sont oui
c'est normal que la jeunesse comtesse si
elle n'était contestez pas elle serait
pas jeunes et les pays africains ont
leurs propres problèmes les dirigeants
africains le savent parfaitement en
revanche nous avons une communauté de
langue une communauté de formation nous
avons on se comprend assez bien et les
africains connaissent les défauts
français et connaissent aussi les
qualités et les africains ne sont
absolument pas dupes des français ni les
russes ni les chinois et ils savent ce
que nous sommes parce que ils vivent
avec nous et nous vivons avec eux moi je
suis allé très souvent en afrique pour
des raisons professionnelles et en
respectant évidemment le même partenaire
dont je constate que ces pays évolue
bien mais n'évolue pas d'une façon
strictement linéaire nous avons caresser
un moment une vingtaine d'années l'idée
que toutes les élections et les
présidents succéderait son problème le
mouvement a lancé
le mouvement de balancier et est
malheureusement inévitable et nous avons
eu des coups d'état la volonté des
jeunes africains que dont vous parlez
mais c'est d'avoir eu aussi une
démocratie merci sylvain garcia gérard
longuet vous faites partie de la
campagne de valérie pécresse vous êtes
même dans son dans son conseil de
défense on vous a vu avec d'autres
anciens ministres de la défense
d'ailleurs dont michèle alliot marie sa
compagne est en perdition
sa campagne est difficile et les
difficiles parce que l'actualité
internationale n'a pas permis d'ouvrir
le débat en français lui reste encore
une chance d'être au deuxième tour il
aurait une chance ya quatre candidats
qui sont à peu près entre marine le pen
mélenchon n'est réglé mo est
naturellement valérie pécresse chacun
des quatre peut espérer accéder au
deuxième si nicolas sarkozy dit que se
déclarer si nicolas sarkozy se déclarer
pour emmanuel macron ce week-end comme
d'ailleurs plusieurs sources l'indiquent
nos confrères de nice matin est ce que
ce serait un tsunami pour la campagne de
valérie pécresse
moi je commence je termine toujours les
guerres dans le camps dans lesquels je
les ai commencé ça serait pas le cas là
et si nicolas sarkozy qu'est le
fondateur des républicains décident est
de s'exonérer
de la vie du parti qu'il a créé et dont
il reste un aspirateur ce serait chez
nous un grand étonnement
vous sentez que ça va être le cas
je crois qu'il faut distinguer
l'autorité intellectuelle de l'ancien
président de la république lorsqu'il
conseille emmanuel macron et la fidélité
de cet homme a une famille politique qui
lui a permis d'être président et qui a
avec lui des relations de
ce qui est mon cas de respect et
d'affection mais je ne pense pas qu'il
prenne serait cette rupture vous
pourriez aller travailler pour le bien
du pays avec emmanuel macron je pense
qu'il faudra une coalition à un moment
ou un autre dans ce pays pourquoi parce
que vous ne pouvez pas réformer les
retraites
vous ne pouvez pas changer l'école vous
ne pouvez pas financer une défense et il
la faire évoluer vers une défense
européenne avec même dans ce cas là vous
mais y aller même 30% des voix dans ce
cas là vous pourriez les présidents sont
tous les présidents de la république je
termine tous les présidents de la
république ont cru être majoritaire
alors que leur seule véritable soutien
c'est le premier tout et ils n'ont
jamais su faire travailler les
partenaires du deuxième plan moi j'ai
voté manuel macron au deuxième tour de
2017 à aucun moment emmanuel macron m'a
dit mon cher monsieur longuet ce que
vous dites c'est intéressant parlons-en
les prêts d'ailleurs ses prédécesseurs
non plus tous sont est élu au deuxième
tour et aucun n'a respecté ses électeurs
du deuxième tour merci gérard longuet
ancien ministre de la défense d'avoir
été l'invité de face aux territoires
vous êtes sénateur de la meuse au revoir
à tous les programmes continus sur tv5
monde merci à vous
[Musique]